there is no new Administration policy
with respect to the border wall from day
one this Administration has made clear
that a border wall is not the answer the
construction project reported today was
appropriated funded during the prior
Administration in
2019 and the law requires the government
to use these funds for this purpose we
have repeatedly asked Congress to resend
this money but it has not done so and we
are compelled to follow the
law that is Homeland Security secretary
Alam jomi orcz saying the Biden
Administration is still against border
walls even though he just lifted 26 laws
to build one we're talking to a Rancher
with a pile of materials for the project
just sitting on his land he wants of
course Biden to finally use it but first
Brook singman has more on the mixed
signals coming out of the White House
hey Brook yeah guys that's right
President Biden now says Congress
shoulders the blame for reconstruction
of former president Trump's border wall
listen to this I'll answer one question
on the border wall the border wall the
money was appropriated for the border
wall I tried to get them to
reappropriate to redirect that money
they didn't they wouldn't and in the
meantime there's nothing under the law
other than they have to use the money
for what it was appropriated I can't
stop that do you believe the border wall
MKS no and now his own party is turning
on him New York congresswoman Alexandria
oazo Cortez Le in the Progressive push
back saying quote the Biden
Administration was not required to
expand construction of the border wall
and they certainly were not required to
wave several environmental laws to
expedite the building the president
needs to take responsibility for this
decision and reverse the course but the
White House is doubling down saying the
change really isn't their fault listen
he said there will not be another foot
of Wall constructed in my Administration
so something changed what you want us to
break the law
is that what you want you want us to not
comply with the law you want us to not
be in administrations that follow the
you guys do this all the time the
student loans uh the student loan
forgiveness program uh you went to court
to fight for that if this is such a
problem building 20 mi of wall why not
just go to court we went to
Congress yeah guys so you'll remember on
his first day in office Biden issued an
executive order to Halt all border wall
construction he called the border
security measure a quote waste of money
and quote not a serious policy solution
Biden's order halted 173 mil of Border
Construction after Trump left office and
in another stunning reversal the Biden
Administration says it will resume
deporting Venezuelan migrants announcing
last month that they would give them
temporary protected status guys they are
all over the map all right Brook thank
you so much let's bring in New Mexico
Rancher Russell Johnson and Russell this
issue of course hits so close to home
for you because you got that pile of
Border material sitting on your property
so what do you think of this back and
forth yesterday where the president said
that he's going to build 20 mi of border
wall in South Texas but only because his
hands are tied he still does not think
that walls
work good morning Carly and I appreciate
the opportunity to come on the show I I
I find it funny that this Administration
is all of a sudden worried about
following the rule of law here in this
scenario but what's frustrating to me is
I I live in New Mexico which falls under
uh boorder of patrols El Paso sector and
and fiscal year 2023 Al Paso sector had
over 389,000 encounters on the Southwest
border here and RGV had 245,000 which
according to this Administration and
secretary my orcus triggered an acute
need for a border
wall what does 389,000 Crossings in El
Paso sector mean is that classify as
some kind of emergency that's what's
frustrating to me is I'm sitting here in
New Mexico with a wide open border yet
20 miles of walls being disputed down in
Texas it's a really good point and to
follow up on what Carly said sort of the
administration being all over the place
I have a contrarian view on this to me
this looks like Joe Biden in the
administration is trying to convince the
voters that hey we're doing something on
the border they see their poll numbers
plummeting they see the American people
Democrat Republican independent don't
want this influx that's happening in
your community and in Texas and
throughout the southern border my
problem with this though if they win
reelection which would happen 13 months
from now my gut tells me that the border
wall is going to stop and the influx is
going to be able to resume once again
and people like you are just going to
you know get the shaft once again do you
share my view on
that I sure do it's it's very
frustrating for us down here on the
border because our Safety and Security
hinges on whoever is in power in the
White House and and we feel like just
political ponds down here that nobody
really cares about when it comes down to
it and it's very frustrating for all of
us living down here because none of it's
being taken seriously particularly by
this Administration yeah totally and and
it seems like it's only this 20 Mile
Stretch is being built now that it's
becoming an issue in the major cities
how do you feel about that and also you
do really bring up a good point about it
them fighting over just this tiny little
portion that they're going to build in
South Texas when wide open space where
you are so tell us about what's going on
in your backyard how often are you
seeing border crossers and how has it
impacted
you so with the 3/4 mile Gap that we
have on our ranch right now uh the
summer months kind of slow things down
because we were seeing weeks well over
100 degrees and so it kind of slowed
things down but we're starting to cool
off so we're starting to see a little
little increase in foot traffic but if
if you start closing off borders in just
small sections but you don't seal off
the entire border where do you think
that traffic's going to go so if they
start building 20 miles in Texas they're
they're just going to keep moving to
those Paths of least least resistance
totally and so that's what's kind of
ironic is you're going to build 20 miles
and you really think that's going to do
anything so like you say it's it's
purely a political move to to make it
seem like they're trying to do something
and they care about the situation when
the reality is it's just politics and
Russell I was also reading that your dad
and uncle had their pickup truck stolen
at gumpoint at one point you've also had
cattle stolen as
well we have my family's been down here
in this area for over a hundred years so
I mean we've seen just about anything
imaginable that can happen the the
pickup being stolen that was in the 90s
uh cattle stolen that's been in the 90s
early 2000s we we've seen the the whole
gamut of what could happen down here on
the border and it's all been horrible
things looking at the video once again
let's rack that I thought it was going
to be like a couple fences Russell there
is a lot of material do you have any
guesstimate how much money our federal
government is wasting keeping these
border materials on your land I what are
we looking at
here I'd venture to say I mean it's
millions of dollars just in our area
alone and there's there's yards like
this all up and down the southern border
not just in our area that's so much
money just to not only did the C
contracts get cancelled but now uh
contractors are being paid to to house
this material that was already allocated
it's ready to go and it's just sitting
out here rusting if you're a taxpayer
it's very frustrating you're looking at
this video you see your taxpayer dollars
going to pay for migrants to stay $500 a
night in hotels you look at what
happened in Afghanistan billions upon
billions of dollars like here you go
enemy take this as a taxpayer you just
have your blood boil and you just
yourself totally is that is that border
material still usable at this
point oh yes it's this material that was
brought in here is us-made steel it was
brand new when it came in I mean it it's
it's perfect ready to go all we need to
do is install it yeah exactly Russell
what a wild turn of events when it comes
to the administration stance on if
border walls work or not uh but thank
you for joining us this morning and
telling your story it's an interesting
one we appreciate it I'm Steve duy I'm
Brian kilme and I'm Angley aart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis